Dylan says this there's a picture that's
gonna end there or whatever yeah is it
you with a guy
this whole time I've been thinking of
something regarding Nina no no bro this
makes way more sense yes
now I'm reconsidering because because we
had a face to face I told you this we
sat down at a table me and Dylan yep he
was asked about that photo and I was
like bro you know what I think
I think you're a liar so I was like
you've seen you have this photo
why don't you post it so God I
have a photo boo I call this Bluff I
said no you don't and even if you did
even if you did have some
grotesque the range explicit photo
this dude was dumb enough to
sweat about having the photo
transferring it already which is a crime
in itself he didn't send it to me I
asked though come on